[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui dans science
clic les symétries de l'univers les lois
qui régissent notre univers peuvent
paraître complexes et nombreuses
conservation de l'énergie principes
d'action réaction relativité générale
modèle standard des particules pourtant
toute cette complexité émerge d'un
concept plus profond plus purs dont
toutes ces lois ne sont que conséquence
les symétries en mathématiques
une symétrie est une transformation qui
laisse un objet inchangée une sphère par
exemple présente une symétrie de
rotation on peut tourner autour changer
d'orientation
elles restent identiques une corde
infinie est symétrique par translation
on peut se décaler le long de la corde
elle reste identique
il se trouve que l'univers lui aussi
peut présenter des symétries une
symétrie de l'univers est une
transformation qui n'affecte pas les
lois de la physique pour comprendre
imaginons un univers vide dans lequel on
réalise une expérience toute simple on
lance une balle une fois lâchés elle
continue d'avancer tout droit à vitesse
constante
maintenant imaginons qu'on se décale
dans l'univers et qu'on réalise la même
expérience
un autre endroit ici aussi on observe
que la balle continue en ligne droite à
vitesse constante
elle se comporte de la même façon les
lois de la physique auquel elle obéit
n'ont pas changé d'un endroit à l'autre
cet univers obéit donc à une symétrie de
translation on peut se décaler dans
l'univers réaliser l'expérience un autre
endroit
le résultat est le même cet univers vide
obéit également à une symétrie par
rotation on aurait pu se tourner changer
d'orientation
le résultat aurait été le même enfin cet
univers est également symétrique dans le
temps on aurait pu attendre et lancer la
balle un peu plus tard des lois de la
physique ne change pas d'un instant à
l'autre le fait que l'univers obéissent
à des symétries que les lois de la
physique
restent les mêmes après certaines
transformations impose des restrictions
sur le comportement des objets pour
comprendre
reprenons notre univers vide et lens ont
la balle
une fois lancé la balle acquiert un
mouvement vers l'avant et à l'instant
suivant elle se situe légèrement plus
loin elle a changé de position mais si
on suppose que l'univers est symétrique
par translation
c'est à dire que les lois de la physique
restent les mêmes lorsqu'on change de
position alors la situation est
équivalente à l'instant précédant la
balle s'est décalé mais les lois de la
physique
restent les mêmes à cet endroit et à
chaque instant elle va donc évoluer de
la même façon si les lois de la physique
sont invariante par translation la
symétrie force la balle a conservé son
mouvement ce qui explique qu'elle trace
une ligne droite à vitesse constante
[Musique]
de façon analogue si un objet tourne sur
lui même et en supposant cette fois ci
que les lois de la physique sont
symétriques par rotation à l'instant
suivant la situation est équivalente et
la symétrie va donc forcé l'objet a
conservé sa rotation
[Musique]
ainsi chaque symétrie de l'univers pour
être respectées impose la conservation
d'une grandeur la conservation de la
quantité de mouvement pour les
translations du moment cinétique pour
les rotations et de l'énergie pour la
symétrie temporel on appelle ce principe
le théorème de notr chaque symétrie de
l'univers impose la conservation d'une
grandeur au cours du temps le théorème
de notr s'applique également au contenu
de l'univers et en particulier au chant
quantique qui constituent la matière
elle-même un champ quantique peut lui
aussi présenté et des symétries le champ
des électrons par exemple est constitué
de nombreux complexes et les lois de la
physique qui décrivent les électrons ne
change pas lorsqu'on des phases tous ces
nombres complexes en même temps
pour comprendre imaginons qu'on mesure
l'altitude d'un avion sur terre pour
exprimer l'altitude de l'avion
on doit fixer un niveau de référence par
exemple le niveau de la mer en fixant
cette référence
on peut décrire l'altitude par un nombre
mais ce choix de référence est
arbitraire on aurait pu choisir un autre
niveau
on aurait mesuré des valeurs différentes
mais la situation physique n'a pas
changé pour autant une même situation
peut être décrite différemment en
fonction du niveau de référence que l'on
choisit de la même façon pour le chant
des électrons on peut changer de niveau
de référence ce qui revient à faire
tourner la phase des nombres complexes
sans que cela n'affecte la situation
physique qui est décrite
ce changement de référence constitue une
symétrie et d'après le théorème de notr
cette symétrie impose elle aussi la
conservation d'une grandeur c'est la
charge électrique
les lois de conservation comme la
conservation de l'énergie ou de la
charge électrique ne sont donc pas
fondamental en général ces grandeurs
n'ont pas de raison particulière d'être
conservé cette uniquement lorsque
l'univers présente une symétrie sous
jacente que pour être respecté cette
symétrie impose la conservation d'une
grandeur le principe d'action réaction
par exemple qui traduit la conservation
de la quantité de mouvement lorsque deux
objets se séparent n'est qu'une
conséquence de la symétrie par
translation
si l'un des objets par dans un sens
l'autre doit partir dans l'autre sens
grâce à cette symétrie les fusées
peuvent décoller vers le haut en
éjectant de la matière vers le bas
[Musique]
un problème se pose alors contrairement
à l'exemple simplifiée d'un univers vide
notre univers réel ne semble pas
complètement symétrique à l'échelle des
milliards d'années par exemple
l'universe expan il n'est donc pas
parfaitement symétrique au cours du
temps en conséquence à grande échelle
l'énergie dans l'univers n'est pas
conservé la lumière par exemple perd peu
à peu de l'énergie sa longueur d'onde
est étiré à mesure que l'univers ce
expan l'univers n'est pas non plus
parfaitement symétrique par translation
il contient des étoiles et des planètes
si bien qu'à cette échelle il n'est pas
le même partout
ainsi si on lâche un objet en général sa
quantité de mouvement n'est pas conservé
sur terre par exemple une pomme tombe
vers le bas elle accélère son mouvement
change au cours du temps car la
situation n'est pas symétrique
[Musique]
a priori notre univers semble ne pas
respecter de symétrie pire encore les
lois de la physique semble différente en
fonction du référentiel depuis lequel on
observe lorsqu'on lâche une balle à
l'intérieur d'une centrifugeuse
si on observe depuis l'extérieur la
balle semble conserver son mouvement
mais si on observe depuis l'intérieur
le mouvement de la balle n'est pas
conservé elle accélère vers la surface
comment expliquer que la balle se
comportent différemment
a priori les lois de la physique sont
absolus
si l'on veut une bonne description de
notre univers on souhaiterait que tous
les objets quel que soit notre point de
vue obéissent toujours aux mêmes lois
lorsqu'on change de point de vue les
lois de l'univers ne devrait pas changer
elles restent les mêmes pour tout le
monde pourtant le comportement de la
balle n'est pas le même pour régler ce
problème pour rétablir le caractère
absolu des lois de la physique que la
balle soit décrite par les mêmes lois
selon les deux points de vue il va être
nécessaire d'ajouter un nouvel élément à
notre description pour comprendre
reprenons l'analogie précédente on
mesure l'altitude d'un avion l'avion
avance tout droit et si l'on prend comme
référence le niveau de la mer on mesure
une altitude constante
il trace une ligne droite cela dit
imaginons maintenant que l'on prenne
comme référence la surface de la terre
cette fois ci à cause des montagnes on
mesure une altitude qui varient au cours
du temps comme si l'avion se déplaçait
en zigzag
en prenant comme référence la surface de
la terre
le comportement de l'avion semble
désormais différent pourtant la
situation n'a pas changé
l'avion avance tout droit comment
expliquer qu'en avançant tout droit
son altitude varie au cours du temps
pour résoudre ce paradoxe il est
nécessaire d'introduire un genre de
champ de force qui pousserait l'avion
vers le haut ou vers le bas en fonction
du niveau de référence que l'on a choisi
expliquant ainsi son comportement
[Musique]
lorsqu'on passe d'un niveau de référence
à un autre du niveau de la mer au niveau
de la surface terrestre
il est nécessaire d'ajouter ce champ de
force pour bien tenir compte du
comportement de l'avion
[Musique]
si l'on revient à l'exemple de la balle
dans la centrifugeuse
la situation est exactement la même en
passant d'un point de vue à l'autre de
l'extérieur à l'intérieur
la balle semble obéir à des lois
différentes et il est nécessaire
d'ajouter une sorte de champ de force à
notre description c'est ce qu'on appelle
les forces d'inertie et en particulier
la force centrifuge et la force de
coriolis
en ajoutant ces forces d'inertie ont
rétabli le caractère absolu des lois de
la physique
le comportement de la balle se comprend
désormais très bien dans n'importe quel
référentiel s'ils tentaient qu'on ajoute
ce champ de force qui va dépendre du
point de vue
introduire ce genre de champ de force
sous jacent est également ce qui donne
naissance au concept de courbure de
l'espace temps et à la théorie de la
relativité générale la relativité
générale est une théorie très puissante
précisément car elle rétablit le
caractère absolu des lois de la physique
en ajoutant une nouvelle structure
sous-jacente à l'univers la courbure de
l'espace-temps la relativité générale
permet de décrire l'univers selon
n'importe quel point de vue avec les
mêmes lois
les mêmes équations
[Musique]
de façon assez stupéfiante ce
raisonnement a ajouté un champ pour
rétablir l'invariance des lois de la
physique est également la base de toutes
les interactions fondamentales en
physique des particules
on a vu que le chant quantique des
électrons possède une symétrie les lois
qui le décrivent sont invariante
lorsqu'on des phases tous les nombres
complexes de façon globale mais s'ils
ont des phases différemment les
différentes parties du champ de façon
locale ce qui revient à choisir un
niveau de référence en zigzag comme la
surface de la terre
les lois qui décrivent les électrons
semble avoir changé
en d'autres termes ce changement de
référence n'est pas une symétrie
si l'on veut rétablir le caractère
absolu des lois de la physique rétablir
la symétrie quel que soit le niveau de
référence que l'on choisit on doit
nécessairement changer notre description
il faut introduire une autre structure
sous-jacente une sorte de champ de force
avec lequel interagit le champ des
électrons pour expliquer son changement
de comportement cet autre structure est
ce qu'on appelle le champ
électromagnétique
il contient des particules qui
interagissent avec les électrons les
photons
en quelque sorte si deux objets se
repoussent par leurs charges électriques
si l'on ne traverse pas une chaise
lorsqu'on s'assoit et si la lumière
existent dans l'univers c'est grâce à
cette symétrie locale le fait de pouvoir
changer de niveau de référence pour les
nombres complexes qui requiert
l'existence d'un nouveau champ et de
nouvelles particules les photons avec
lesquels interagissent les électrons
[Musique]
pour conclure l'étude des symétries de
l'univers nous permet de comprendre de
façon profonde l'origine des lois qui le
régissent
c'est parce que l'univers possède des
symétries que les objets qu'il contient
pour respecter ces symétrie obélie stade
éloi conservation de l'énergie ou
principes d'action réaction
les objets n'obéissent à ses lois que
pour respecter des symétries sous
jacente propres à l'univers en
considérant que les lois de la physique
doivent être absolue que changer de
point de vue ou de niveau de référence
doit constituer une symétrie qui
n'affecte pas la réalité physique on
parle de symétrie de jauge on déduit la
présence de nouvelles structures dans
l'univers comme la courbure de l'espace
temps où le champ électromagnétique
expérimentalement les symétries
permettent également de dévoiler les
mystères cachés de la matière en
mesurant certaines propriétés des
particules et en étudiant les diagrammes
géométriques que l'on obtient les
symétries ont permis notamment de
comprendre que les protons neutrons et
autres par ion sont formées de trois
objets plus petits qui obéissent à une
symétrie fondamentale basé sur le nombre
3 les quark
il existe également des symétries
discrète par exemple inversé la charge
la direction dans l'espace et la
direction dans le temps de toutes les
particules constitue une symétrie une
antiparticule peut être interprété de
cette façon comme une particule
ordinaire qui remonte le temps
enfin certaines théories modernes encore
spéculative postule que l'univers
pourrait posséder une symétrie encore
plus profonde
une symétrie entre les particules de
matière et les particuliers
d'interaction comme si toutes deux
obéissaient aux mêmes lois
c'est la supersymétrie
[Musique]